where are you where are you exactly
I managed to book you a slot in America
I'm sorry can you say that again he just
announced Lessman adds Jordan get for
gonna guess and what is oh no you're not
wearing that you look like a nut okay
lastly
can't leave alone xoxo it's like I'm
making up for somebody in the past life
coming in
is there Wi-Fi on the bus dude kill
yourself on the king of this kingdom
this is amazing your whole life is going
to change I tell these people what to
like I've seen more djs than you can
count come and go it is a tough business
sooner you realize that the easier is
going to be for you this music means
everything to me I'm in this because I
love it
this is real music is that meant to be
the soundtrack to getting wasted or the
background to a car commercial when you
make that connection to somebody it gets
you outside yourself
I always felt like this nothing kid when
I was out there in the middle of his
massive crowd I felt like you were part
of something
way bigger yeah
who's a huge party going on out there
man
the [ __ ]
we're in this together trust me
and we're gonna play an amazing set and
I am gonna be there
this is your moment you gotta grab it
sigh she's an emergency sorry don't
worry I have to go first I'm American
give me that